die letzten Minuten vor dem lifegang die
letzten 10 Monate channeln alle in
diesem Moment noch nie so lang an einem
Projekt gearbeitet was dann so einfach
da ist völlig verrückt das bin ich
unheimlich übermüdet und angespannt
wenige Minuten vor dem Launch meiner App
warum ich zurecht angespannt war wie der
Launch lief und wie es jetzt mit der App
weitergeht erfahrt ihr in der fünften
Folge der
startupreihe zwei Optionen es läuft gut
es läuft in dem Moment gut wo die App
nicht abschmiert wo uns niemand probiert
zu hacken irgendwie anzugreifen
irgendeine Scheiße zu machen Option 2 es
läuft nicht gut das ist der Weg in dem
uns jemand angreift die App crasht
irgendwas passiert wir haben uns bestens
vorbereitet ne Pen Test also Penetration
Test Last Tests wir haben alles gemacht
aber was uns jetzt in den nächsten paar
Minuten erwartet können wir natürlich
nicht
vorhersehen öffentlich fertig speichern
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott ja 1000 sind
jetzt dazu gekommen seitdem du live
geschalten hast wie viel vis hat das
Video das Video hat nur 6000 views
bisher ja wie wunderbar los geht's wie
viel App Downloads haben wir jetzt
insgesamt also n erschrecken die erste
Zahl stimmt nicht ganz das sind quasi
die die jetzt nicht vollwertige Accounts
sind die nicht das Ding sind sind
31500 die 31500 31500 und die anderen
die schon in der appind 20600 sind schon
in der App oh wir sind bei Google
playore sind schon auf Platz 55 bei
Shopping save it ist 23 in Shopping bei
Apple also gerade sind wir in den
Overall Charts so wie ich das sehe im
App Store noch auf
97 jetzt sch 97 ja ja also unsere Server
die halten auf jeden Fall noch aus Video
freigeschaltet App in allen AppStores
verfügbar über den Browser zu erreichen
und so weiter ab diesem Zeitpunkt uns
als Gründer der App auch nichts anderes
mehr übrig als zu beobachten und
irgendwann war die letzte Mail
geschrieben die App released und ich
konnte das erste Mal seit 10 Monaten
vernünftig schlafen nicht zuletzt wegen
den Produkten von Emma dem Partner des
heutigen Videos so flauschig Licht
wieder an ich habe über die letzten
Wochen und Monate einfach gemerkt wie
viel guter und richtiger Schlaf ausmacht
und wie viel produktiver ich über den
gesamten Tag hinweg bin für mich gibt es
nichts ungemütlicheres als zu warm zu
schlafen der Premium Chopper und das
flauschkissen von Emma schaffen hierbei
ab Hilfe und das nicht nur im Sommer
sondern egal in welcher Jahreszeit denn
sie wirken temperaturreulierend und
führen überschüssige Wärme ganz einfach
ab und sind nebenbei noch unheimlich
flauschig noch bis zum 30.11 sind bei
Emma blackweeks was bedeutet dass
unheimlich viele Produkte bis zu 50%
reduziert sind über diesen QR Code oder
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
kommt ihr in den Shop und könnt mit dem
Code Startup noch mal 5% on top sparen
auch auf bereits reduzierte Wagen und
das war's noch nicht Emma wäre nicht
Partner der Startup Reihe wenn sie nicht
auch einen Deal über savet h deswegen
gibt es Nur Heute exklusiv einen ganz
besonderen Deal für alle SAV it Nutzer
in unserer App um extra on top noch mal
was bei Emma zu sparen also checkt euren
AppStore aus ladet euch SAV it runter
und sichert euch den nur heute
exklusiven em Deal über SAV it ja und
wenn ihr die Betten Kissen und Matratzen
einmal selbst testen wollt dann könnt
ihr das hier in Köln in der Nähe vom
Rudolfplatz im ersten em Store
Deutschlands tun wo auch wenn nicht in
Köln meiner Heimatstadt checkt das gerne
aus wenn ihr Bock habt vielen Dank
wieder einmal an Emma fürs möglich
machen dieses Formates und Stützen
dieses Kanals Links findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung ab 10.11 hier in Köln
alle Produkte selber testen jetzt viel
Spaß weiter mit dem Video und ja durch
die Produkte von Emma konnte ich gut
schlafen trotz alledem gab es ein
ziemlich böses Erwachen und das nicht
wegen dem Fehler von uns sondern wegen
dem Hackerangriff in den letzten 30
Minuten kommen bei einigen die
registrierungsmails nicht mehr an und
wir arbeiten an einer Lösung mit der ihr
gleich wieder reinkommt es tut uns
schrecklich leid wir sind tatsächlich
eingeklappt trotz guter Vorbereitung ja
tatsächlich wir wurden gehackt od es
wurde zumindest versucht uns auf die
Nerven zu gehen aber wir haben das beste
Developer Team der ganzen Welt und
konnten uns dem Hackerangriff
widersetzen seht ihr das das ist das
verrückte Chaos hier Kamera vier
Flaschen Mate irgendwelche Getränke die
uns zugeschickt wurden und ich bin
komplett durch mittlerweile ist ein Tag
nach Release die App ist noch nicht mal
24 Stunden online wir stehen aktuell bei
125 000 registrierten Nutzer was
komplett geisteskrank ist aber das
bringt nicht Vorteile mit sich im
Prinzip gab es zwei Methoden mit denen
versucht wurde uns zu Schaden in den
ersten Tagen wurden wir nämlich drei bis
vier Mal am Tag versucht zu diossen so
nennt man das es wurden Millionen von
Anfragen in kürzester Zeit geschickt das
war kein Problem unsere Firewall ist
standhaft geblieben und alles war best
was allerdings ein Problem war jemand
hat weiß herrgt warum sich mit 7in5000
Fake E-Mails bei uns versucht 7in5000
Fake Konten zu erstellen das hat dazu
geführt dass 7in5000 E-Mails nicht
zugestellt werden konnen unser Service
AWS Amazon Server haben das mitbekommen
und gemerkt okay 7in5000 Mails können
nicht zugestellt werden die sogenannte
Bounce Rate ist zu hoch zu viele Mails
kommen zurück und um uns zu schützen
wurde unser E-Mailverkehr eingestellt
und wir konnten keine weiteren E-Mails
mehr senden das war problematisch weil
wir dadurch keine registrierungsmails
mehr schicken konnten wodurch Leute
ihren Account registrieren konnen
mittlerweile haben wir dafür auch einen
Sicherheitsmechanismus eingebaut wir
können wieder Mails schicken und alles
ist wunderbar das hat uns aber eine
Menge Nerven und eine Menge Zeit
gekostet wir konnten aber sehr schnell
reagieren das bedeutet kein Fehler auf
unserer Seite sondern irgendwelche
Spaßvögel von euch vielen Dank jetzt
wissen wir mehr gestern sind dadurch für
eine Stunde lang ganz entspannte 19 000
Nutzer verloren gegangen aber es ist
komplett krank plötzlich melden sich
alle Shops an die wir vielleicht vorher
nicht mal gedacht haben die sie erstmal
abwarten wollten wie es so ist es melden
sich alle Creator worüber wir mega happy
sind die vorher ja keine Ahnung nicht so
überzeugt davon waren oder was auch
immer und tatsächlich guckt euch das mal
an ich habe 1300
über den Creator Code seit gestern um 18
Uhr verdient das ist 18 Stunden her von
den 10 Stunden lang Nacht
war das ist komplett geisteskrank hab
Sascha dabei der Kohle sammelt wir
brauchen noch ein passendes Auto ich
finde den Renault Twizy wahnsinnig geil
und ich würde gern den Renault Twizy
über den Creator Code generieren um den
Renault Twizy an die Community
zurückzugeben Creator Code Twizy emoji
neu dabei rumatra maxify plus die ganzen
Leute die wir schon hatten wir kommen
gar nicht hin hher alle Leute
freizuschalten also wirklich von A bis Z
sind die Creator dabei sind Pump da
drauf und wir sind mega happy aber es
gibt natürlich auch die wirkliche
rabatamter Community die findet sich
häufig auf mydeals wir haben einen
Beitrag zu uns gemacht bei dem man sieht
wie die Verteilung ist dieses
kuchendiagramm zeigt an welche Plattform
wie viele topdeals hat also topdeals im
Sinne von das beste Cashback für z.B
möbelhöffner das irgendwo im Internet zu
finden ist und in 40% der Fällen haben
wir das Beste Cashback von allen
Plattformen überhaupt also wir haben 112
Top Deals Schub hat nur 14 und igral
auch und wir haben die Deals gemacht
während noch Null Nutzer auf der App
waren und die Shops die App noch nicht
mal gesehen haben also überlegt mal was
alles noch möglich ist wenn wir jetzt in
der Woche noch mal mit denen sprechen
und sagen ja jetzt sind 250 000 Leute
drauf und wir das direkt an euch und an
die Creator weitergeben 100.000 User
haben wir nach knapp 6 Stunden geknackt
was unseren Informationen nach der
erfolgreichste App Launch Deutschlands
jemals ist das ist richtig verrückt nach
24 Stunden hatten wir 145 000 User und
im Vergleich zu unseren internen
Hoffnung bis zum Ende des Jahres 100.000
Nutzer zu haben ist das völlig balaballa
also ein riesen Dankeschön an jeden von
euch der die App runtergeladen hat falls
ihr es noch nicht getan habt über diesen
QR Code oder den Link in der
Videobeschreibung könnt ihr das gerne
tun Creator Code Dave auswählen und beim
Online Shoppen bares Geld sparen aber
ich wäre nicht Dave wenn der Clue hier
enden würde in einer der letzten Folgen
hatte ich schon angerissen dass wir uns
mit 7 VSS wild so ein bisschen was
ausgedacht haben deswegen haben wir
parallel zu dieser Startup Serie von der
ihr jetzt schon einige Folgen gesehen
habt noch ein paar seven Verss wild
Spots produziert die in Hauptserie auf
freevie Hauptserie auf Youtube und
behind the scenes Serie von 7 vs wild
Staffel 3 laufen werden dafür haben wir
alle Wälder im Kölner Umland über ein
paar Wochen unsicher gemacht und eine
Menge Zeug produziert und das erste
placement ging zwei Tage nach
veröffentlichen der App auch schon
online ach ja und für alle die das S
Vers W place nicht gesehen haben wir
verlosen in Kooperation mit 7 V wild ein
Land Rover Defender so richtig kranken
Land Rover Defender so ein originalen
also Instagram Seite von 7 auschecken
und am Gewinnspiel teilnehmen und dann
vielleicht bald eigenen Land Rover
Defender auf Abenteuerreise
gehen einach ich habe einfach
denn machen was ich
[Musik]
will und dann übelst krank richtig krank
alles geschafft jetzt on time und jetzt
muss ich schnell eine Story machen es
geht los seven Verss wild behind the
scenes Leo
Daniel und ich wir haben vor Ort alles
bestmöglich mit der Kamera begleitet und
jetzt sehen wir was daraus geworden sind
wir sind richtig gespannt dieses Mal
bedeutet un für uns kein Stress sondern
nur genießen klickt hier drauf gönnt
euch selber die neue Staffel die scenes
wir sind mega gespannt nun ja was soll
ich sagen nach dem ersten 7 V wild
placement und einer Menge Werbung meiner
influencer Kollegen die ihren eigenen
Creator Code beworben haben konnten wir
nach 72 Stunden nach Launch der App
schon 200.000 Nutzer knackpp
mittlerweile sind wir über 250.000
Nutzer und wir konnten 10000 € an
Cashback ausschien nicht 10 nicht 20
nicht 30 wie viel genau werde ich in
einem der kommenden Videos noch drauf
eingehen also vergesst nicht den Kanal
zu abonnieren wir sehen uns am Sonntag
zu einem neuen Video oder vielleicht
sogar einer neuen Serie wieder also
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
das Video zu macht es gut bis nächsten
Sonntag